hello everybody
have you ever heard anybody say that a
language is difficult have you ever say
somebody say Russian Chinese or Japanese
are very hard to learn well I did hear
them and I have to tell you that I just
wondered at the beginning before
learning Chinese for example what does
it mean that Chinese is so hard to learn
in general in languages there's a lot of
aspects that might possibly pose some
problems on thought teeth so to say to
the people who want to learn them let's
consider Russian for example it's it's
grammar isn't totally difficult there's
a lot of people think that it's quite
impossible to learn a language like
Russian and there's a lot of Russians
and the Russians themselves they're very
very surprised if they meet up with a
person but they stumble upon a person
who can speak even a couple of phrases
in a Russian without staggering and
without stumbling other words I wouldn't
call I wouldn't use the word hard
I want to infuse the word easy as far as
language another concern I would use the
word complex rather than difficult and I
won't I want to explain to you why I
have this vision let's consider one more
time Russian for example there's there
are the notoriously infamous cases that
make very difficult for a corner there
are a jackman not only you know
Casey's concern announced objectives and
verbs have aspects verbs of movement are
also very difficult emblematic example I
want to say I want to go to Russia or
you want to come here I went to there's
a lot of different combinations and
hurdles but let's consider is an example
sentence like I made I made up with a
girl I met up with a girl in English as
well I am the subject and I met up with
a friend I'm sorry I am the subject
who's talking girl man if you're looking
to me of course I am a man
if you if you come across a sentence in
a book and you know the subject and it's
sex
you wouldn't know who's talking and
saying goes for a curtain for the person
the friend and he/she are going to meet
so what I want to see is the English it
lacks a little bit of position in this
regard of course you can use other words
in order to explain thoroughly and and
give definition to those sex and the
object of the sentence but in in Russian
if you say the same thing it's very
clear the sex of the person of the
subject and the sex of the person that
the subject has to meet our very clear
evidence adamant since the very
beginning so what I want to say is that
people who tend to see these rules as
difficult tend to let will label them
and perceive them as hurdles while
learners who seem receive them as a tool
they may see and they see it as a tool
for precision it means that I tend to
see something difficult as something
complex and talking about rushing but
let's consider Chinese for example a lot
of people say Chinese is one of the most
length most difficult languages of the
world this is one of the most well known
facts accepted facts of the language
learning language learning community but
I wouldn't call it hard I would of
course tones oh they are a problem at
the beginning and but Chinese is not as
difficult as a lot of people say it
remember that it didn't I had never I
had never wanted to learn Chinese
because my aunt kept telling me that
it's all celebs you know it was so so
impossible for her and then when I
started learning I found some
difficulties but the the real complex
thing about Chinese is the characters of
Chinese characters if you want to write
them well it takes years no matter what
you do no matter how hard you learn it
will take years before you master master
there's no such thing as masking a thing
but yeah it takes years in order to
learn and properly to learn at least of
the 4000 most care and most known
characters
um so what I wanted to say and also
there's another aspect that makes a
little bit complex as a language and
it's because it's a totally different
mentality so what you have to do is do
you have to get into the mentality enter
the mentality EPEL think that language
is a vehicle for that mentality so you
have to understand that I'm telling you
know it takes a lot of time so I tend to
you always use the word complex instead
of the word difficult we talked about
difficulty or that in language is
difficult or easy also because I also
dependent on our native tongue I'm
Italian so a lot of people might think
that learning Spanish is quite easy for
an Italian says the two languages are
very very similar but learning language
to a c2 level or very high level c2 it's
just a european standard it's something
that takes a long time because I think
that I see Spanish as a complex language
and a complex language anyway for for a
Chinese it's learning a language is like
building a cathedral or building a
castle and if you see something
difficult since the very beginning you
will find it difficult when you learn
but if you see that something complex
rather than difficult you will be
fascinated by its complexity and you
will be you want to learn that
complexity step by step step by step
brick by brick as if it were a wall and
this is the message that I wanted to
enforce that we learn languages and we
have to see in this complex fascinating
and life things rather than difficult
objects to master and this is the
message that I wanted to enforce in the
video thank you for listening to me bye